un sujet déjeuner avec Renault l'autre
jour c'est lui qui a dit cette phrase
magnifique
à propos de la naissance d'un de ses
enfants de sa femme lui dit si tu veux
tu peux revoir un verre de vin et lui a
répondu cette phrase magnifique il a dit
inverse c'est trop et 12 c'est pas assez
c'est exactement ça la dépendance
je suis excessif mais je pense que la
célébrité c'est pas la célébrité c'est
les gens qui ont un talent immense je ne
connais pas une star vraiment digne de
snow qui n'est pas alors pas forcément à
vice mais annexer quelque part c'est
soit soit c'est l'alcool soit c'est la
drogue soit c'est des femmes c'est
l'argent mais je ne connais pas une
personne qui est vraiment réussi à un
niveau exceptionnel qui n'est pas
quelques
une addiction une
grande folie parce que si on n'a pas ce
petit grain de folie on n'est pas on
n'est pas unique moi j'ai eu la chance
de côtoyer il y a pas de star ici
il y a vous il y a Jean-Marie excuse-moi
Jean-Marie est un immense humoriste et
Jean-Marie merci tu rebois quelque chose
moi j'avais mon fils moi le vôtre
n'est-ce pas vous votre vous votre votre
ex à vous c'est votre excès à vous c'est
je pense qu'il est dans le sport je
pense que vous pouvez pas rigoler non
mais je pense que vous êtes intelligent
vraiment Jean-Marie et je finis 2
secondes monsieur Delormeau et après moi
dans ma famille il y avait des gens qui
étaient des vrais stars ils étaient les
deux ils avaient un pet au casque bah
oui ma grand-mère elle est comme elle a
elle a eu un Oscar rendez-vous c'est une
immense actrice elle a quand même sombré
copieusement Malcolm et quant à montant
il était obsédé par les femmes donc je
et après je raconte je reviendrai
d'autres gens que je n'hésiterai pas
mais je ne connais pas une immense star
qui n'est pas un petit une petite dose
de folie
intéressante
c'est tous les chanteurs qui tombent
dans la dépression ou dans la drogue
c'est et c'est la question à Jean-Marie
quand tu fais un stade de France qui a
80000 personnes tu envoient une décharge
d'adrénaline c'est une drogue chez toi
avec ta femme qui dit tu as ramené le
pain enfin Justin Bieber a dit que même
Juliette Armanet a dit derrière tu
portes plus et du coup tu vas compenser
avec des artifices comment tu comment tu
reprends une vie normale quand tu fais
des tournées comme ça je peux pas moi
j'ai pris un peu d'avance sur le Stade
de France j'étais mort de peur 48 heures
avant et le jour même j'avais déjà passé
l'obstacle c'est-à-dire au moment où
tout le monde me disait mais ça va je
disais oui ça va c'est le jour où toute
mon équipe était comme ça le jour de
l'événement mais moi je l'avais déjà
traversé
une vie normale après j'ai pris mon
petit déjeuner trois biscottes un petit
peu de de beurre salé et puis ça a été
très très bien je l'ai j'ai pas voulu un
seul journaliste à mon Stade de France
j'ai voulu faire le truc tout seul et
puis de donc je lis très bien digérer
j'ai tout le monde m'a dit que c'était
impossible à faire j'ai réussi mon coup
et ça s'est passé sans sans accroc sans
vague j'ai peur je n'ai pas été submergé
si tu veux par mon exploit Marco toi
c'est c'est moi je suis moi je depuis un
an que je suis connu je veux dire la
vérité et je bois un petit verre le soir
mais on a je pense que tout le monde a
un problème c'est quand tu es connu tu
es invité partout déjà à la base tu es
invité partout mais toi tu y vas euh non
attends je suis pas dit fais pas la
peine de l'homme ou Siri je t'ai pas dit
j'y vais je t'ai dit tu es invité mais
moi j'aime moi j'aime pas la maison ah
ouais donc j'aime bien être dehors j'ai
horreur de la maison de tu sais quand tu
fais cette nuit je placard et tu veux
plus être enfermé moi je vois la maison
je tremble je sors à 5h du matin et je
rentre à 4h
c'est une façon de parler
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour ça qu'il a dit ah bon c'est
agréable et la vérité franchement quand
bon on n'est pas au stade de Bigard à
Bigard c'est waouh merci Madame non mais
pour de vrai c'est waouh on s'est
rencontré plusieurs fois dans les
restaurants tu tapais du vent comme j'ai
jamais vu je me dis non mais attends il
y a rien de rien et puis moi je me suis
dit bah il a raison le mec il a raison
il s'éclate et moi je pense que un mec
qui s'arrête tu peux pas faire la morale
à quelqu'un déjà si lui il a pas décidé
d'arrêter quelque chose tu peux faire ta
morale tu peux faire n'importe qui le
docteur il peut te dire que tu vas
mourir tu es bon la dernière cigarette
et tu as continué tu peux pas t'arrêter
donc quand tu bois tes morts pourquoi tu
as pas envie de t'arrêter donc
aujourd'hui moi aussi je bois vers le
soir pour manger avec je kiffe je me
détends et j'oublie tout ce qui se passe
parce que c'est très dur qu'est-ce qui
arrive à tout le monde qui est là ne
croyez pas que c'est pour moi ne croyez
pas que vous êtes une vedette il y a des
trucs positifs énormément mais il y a
beaucoup de négatifs énormément de
négatifs non énormément je te promets
énormément de négatif c'est quoi le
négatif qui devient l'esprit
moi par exemple moi je veux que j'étais
j'ai pas de banque je vais pour me faire
une banque le mec il s'agit de pas me
reconnaître et je lui dis vas-y dis-moi
carrément si tu vas me jeter ou si tu
vas me prendre et il me dit même ce
Mouli non je veux pas vous prendre alors
je dis pourquoi tu fais perdre mon temps
bah ça c'est pas l'autorité c'est parce
que tu as fait cette prison mais il est
bête
[Applaudissements]
chez toi tu me connais pas tu vas dire
bonjour monsieur oui
mais non tu me dis bonjour comment
marcooli donc ça parce que je tu me
connais et comment tu me connais parce
que je viens là donc voilà c'est tout
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable on parlait juste de
célébrités est-ce que la célébrité
pousse au vice Raymond toi qui est
devenu le célèbre non mais c'est vrai
moi j'aurais répondu non à cette
question là célébrités
d'alcool partout il y a des histoires de
cul c'est tout le monde c'est tous les
gens sauf que là célébrité elle a cette
avantage c'est qu'il y a il y a tout le
temps des gens qui vont te tendre la
main quand tu es dans l'alcool bien sûr
le temps de la main parce que tu es
connu il y a quelqu'un qui va te sortir
un mot un moment de la ou alors pas le
fric parce que le fric te donne toutes
les possibilités quelqu'un qui boit chez
lui tout seul et qui est dans
l'alcoolisme parfois il est tout seul
les gens dans dans la vie de tous les
jours c'est pas visible et tu le sais
pas la célébrité tu sais maintenant avec
les réseaux sociaux ça se montre et
voilà Marco tu préfères quand tu étais
connu ou pas connu
alors pour mon boulot je préférais quand
j'étais pas connu
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et là je remonte mes affaires dans à
l'étranger et mais je suis connu aussi
hein
merde
ça me va parce que maintenant je fais un
autre boulot ça veut dire que je
m'arrange avec au contraire que ça
m'amène beaucoup de choses sur Instagram
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sur n'importe quel point tu as vu que je
t'attaquer après j'arrête pas j'ai
entendu des choses d'attaquer ça n'a
aucun sens de la sauce
[Rires]
les gens ils veulent faire des affaires
avec toi tu dépenses pas une thune tu
crois que tu as refait le coin tu vas en
boîte il y a des bouteilles qui tombent
de partout tu dis combien je te dois tu
as pas honte Marco ok je suis un peu
et puis effectivement l'alcool il y en a
partout la drogue il y en a partout donc
il y a pas que les gens célèbres mais il
y a un truc qui est vraiment je trouve
très spécifique de la célébrité c'est la
particule d'accélération par rapport à
la séduction et par rapport aux filles
ou aux garçons je suis désolé il y a
beaucoup de célébrités qui peuvent avoir
beaucoup plus à certaines jeunes filles
ou à certains jeunes garçons qui
n'auraient pas eu
exemple Quesada jurisprudence Quesada
alors là non c'est un cas extrême parce
que lui il est en plus devenu prédateur
jurisprudence PPDA je risque prudence
normale jurisprudence le footballeur
Mendy qui n'est tout d'un coup il a cru
que il était ben oui mais il a été ben
je crois qu'il y a quand même
malgré tout il y avait quand même une
panique rouge chez lui ramener des
filles donc en fait t'as pas accès à
certaines meufs et tout d'un coup tu es
célèbre tu as des nanas il a toujours
été beau gosse non mais c'est vrai non
mais c'est vrai dis la vérité Castle qui
passe mais je dis franchement tu aurais
eu du succès quand même il est beau
gosse Benjamin il faut arrêter il a tout
il était beau gosse
bien sûr
il est dégueulasse et là je vais lui
mettre son avis arrêtez
toi tu as été très très riche est-ce que
quand tu es très très riche tous les
gens qui viennent vers toi deviennent
faux est-ce que tu arrives à chanter
excuse-moi tu parles français ou pas
parce que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la mouche dans le la fausse note le
soufflet au sultan alors est-ce que les
gens enchaînent maintenant est-ce que
l'argent induit la fausseté alors la
réponse là en réalité tu l'as tout le
monde devient faux est-ce que toi avec
Cyril tu es entier
comment ça se fait que tout ce qui dit
Cyril tu dis oui ça va stop dis-moi ça
et tu as tout compris
[Rires]
j'ai pas voulu inter puisque tu me
cherches j'ai pas voulu intervenir parce
que Marco chargée de toi tout à l'heure
tu as parlé d'honnêteté tu te souviens
tu disais à Marco on peut réussir en
étant honnête est-ce que quand tu vends
8 fois le même documentaire à celui de
Disney en changeant pur interview et je
sais pas combien
[Applaudissements]
et toi Mathieu c'est pas grave
les gens qui font comment toi tu commets
si tu avais fait quelque chose tu te
rendrais compte qu'ils sont tous
différents avec un angle différent mais
même sa langue tu étais même pas
journaliste ta carte de presse tu t'es
foutu dans le cul
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
non mais c'est vrai ils vont ils vont
ils vont dix fois le même document alors
nous on lui achète
alors c'est parti
une seule question vous me répondez
honnêtement est-ce que vous lui achetez
parce qu'il vient chaque année vous
implorez achète-moi trois dos que je
sauve ma boîte de production et
attention à ce que vous répondez parce
que j'étais là quand il vous a posé la
question
alors que tu as la sortie du gâteau
Disney a très bien marché sur cible
voilà
[Applaudissements]
qui marche si mal comme l'autre con le
dit elle me fait tourner 4 CDI et 20
personnes pendant que tu mettes ta
petite gueule sur ses news pour gagner
du pognon moi je donne du travail à 20
personnes tu donnes du travail à qui je
n'ai plus besoin du travail je n'ai plus
le droit parce qu'il donne le travail à
qui le droit parce que moi j'ai une
infection parce que vous
pourquoi pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu es une merde
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
qu'on allait attaquer ce sujet pour que
ça crée un débat interne
calme et silencieux
et qui se plateau
merci merci
en tout cas on voit je rappelle que la
question la question était la célébrité
[Rires]
même sans alcoolis non la folie oui vous
pouvez le voir je vais peut-être me
remettre à boire
j'en peux plus alors c'est bon ouais
c'est sympa merci en tout cas ça me fait
plaisir de vous voir comme ça vous allez
quand même pas dormir
ses enfants j'encule mes raisons
[Applaudissements]
tes résolutions
c'est lui qui m'a provoqué vous rendez
compte ce qu'il dit à 26 ans
c'est bon allez calme allez merci
vous allez me retrouver demain
alors pourtant cette discuter
beaucoup mieux tous les deux moi je me
suis dit avant ça m'avait
[Rires]